Film Courage: Why would someone who loves
movies and writing quit the film business?
Kim O’Hara, Author/Book Coach/Speaker/Podcaster:
It’s interesting, we get into an industry that
seems so romantic to other people and people have
said to me Oh my goodness, how could you have been
working in movies and leave? Almost like we’re
beholden to that and now we’re not allowed to
go have a new career and even though there are
many aspects of movies that I loved and continue
to love, there were a lot of areas that were
challenging like distribution for your movie,
financing your movie and you’d spend years putting
together a film, writing it, finding the team,
finding the money, you put a labor of love
into it and then nobody would buy it and
nobody would see it. That to me just was a little
bit too heartbreaking for longer than 20 years.
Film Courage: You made a feature film at 19?
Kim: I made 11 films and I started at 21 and
the first couple ones Calista Flockhart who ended
up becoming Ally McBeal, she was in a film that
we were sort of an associate producer on which is
kind of how you get started when you're young in
in I don't know if it's the same now but
back in the day that's that's what it was
and what that basically meant was is
we found something for free basically
because that's how you operated then
because everybody was on such a shoestring
and then after that you know now you say oh I've
been an associate producer right so then you get
an opportunity to be an associate producer on
another film and then next thing you know it's
just you start to learn more and then you're able
to start taking on producer producer credits did
anyone sit you down in the beginning and say you
know this is a this is a get ready to wait type of
a business and people will tell you all sorts
of stuff and then you'll never hear from them
again or did you have to learn that there were no
mentors we had women in film which I didn't find I
found was a little like non-inclusive and so you'd
volunt I did a couple volunteering gigs there and
then I was like I don't know I don't know it
just it it as a woman in a man's business and
especially as a young woman you didn't really
want to let people know that you didn't know
so there was a lot of kind of fumbling around
in the dark to you learned from your mistakes
basically so when you make one mistake you're
like well let's not make that mistake again
when you worked in hollywood producer writer
production coordinator did you have any other jobs
no I didn't I in the very beginning I was a temp
so when I was in new york city I had some pretty
crazy temp jobs and we were making this movie
we were kind of getting ready to make this movie
at the time and I was really stoked because
I think it wasn't like lehman brothers
or like one of the like I don't remember what the
bank was that the guy went and sold everything
and crashed the whole bank I was there like
working for the person I think I i try to I
can't remember exactly but I look back and I'm
like oh my god I think I reported to his office
but they had these like massive xerox machines
so we needed what was called pages and we also
needed the schedule printed on like blue paper
and green paper and pink paper and we had no money
this is awful but this is what you would do to
make movies is I would sneak into the copy room
and when no one was looking my damn job i'd whip
out like 400 copies of you know a colored schedule
for the for the production okay so and no one
found out no I was pretty wily okay and I did
my job I did my job I got my job done but it was
a little bit too in the in the movie business
that I felt there was this like justification
that as I grew into more integrity in my life
and especially the business I'm in now my
company a story inside I had to look back
and there were a lot of things that you were
kind of expected to do or thought you had to do
to for the art and I look back now and I think
that was one of them it's like I was stealing
if you think about it that wasn't my paper
they were not paying me for that job and we
would do other things like you know fill water
bottles that we had gotten we bought maybe one
poland spring bottle and then we'd fill it
with a hose for the rest of the production
but we wouldn't tell anybody you know just you
know and then you'd be like well it saves money
and it's for the art and I i just over time
you start to think I don't want to try to
unpay people and rip people off anymore it just
doesn't feel like that's what that art should be
sure sure and and was that later on after you
left the film industry that you sort of had that
sort of making amends type exactly I mean I think
because it was every you know like everybody did
it there was just not I mean we were pretty you
know we were pretty sneaky in new york we made
some pretty we did some pretty sneaky things I
think I remember there was a story we didn't do
anything dangerous like we didn't put anybody's
lives at risk and I remember there was that film
where they were like they didn't have a permit
they were shooting on the railroad tracks and a
couple people died wasn't that here in california
recently and I was just thinking oh no we didn't
cross that line yeah we worked in some pretty
scary places we didn't cross that line interesting
and then you left and then I left voluntarily or
the economy it was kind of like I had a baby in
2005. we left los angeles to you know maybe have
a little bit more of like a suburban life which
almost killed me it was a little too suburban
for me it was like I went from echo park in
la which is really rough and like artists over to
suburban san jose and just there wasn't really any
access to any film anymore I tried to keep writing
screenplays I did write one in 2010 and that was
the last one and so contrary to what people say
that you can be anywhere and be writing a script
did you feel that to be true no I think you
have to be in los angeles to take the meetings
meet the people collaborate with others on their
projects right place right time know the attorneys
know the agents I i don't think you can do it
anywhere else have people fought you on that yeah
I mean I haven't really talked to anybody about
it in a while but I think there's those few movies
that are made in other places that originate from
other places you know they're made in florida
and they break through but the breakthrough is
typically through agents or people that are in la
that like might see the film and suggest it for a
festival or they're involved in sundance I think
there's some component that has to be in los
angeles but you did write a script while you
were in the bay area yeah I did I did and those
people had contacted me from my contacts in l.a
so they weren't people I met in the bay area
when you told people in the bay area that you
were in the film industry previously or that you
were writing a script what was their reaction I
don't really think I told anybody oh you didn't
oh okay a closet screenwriter okay I like it I
don't think they they like they had nothing
to do with the film business they were like
they would have been like okay okay I see you
right like your mom's group you know they're
talking about kids I see okay so it never came
up yeah meanwhile I was writing this like her you
know horrific torture script so I don't think it
would have been like a great conversation sure you
wouldn't be invited to the birthday exactly
they'd be like look out watch out for her
you took a part-time job at trader joe's one of
my favorite stores do you want to talk about how
that transition came about sure I think whenever
like you leave something that's your identity
you know I since I was little I always you know
was talking into a hairbrush and so I've actually
discovered I always thought that was an actress
or eventually I thought it was a filmmaker and
lately I've realized it's I want to be a talk show
host right so you know you wake up to that in your
50s and you're like oh my god and it's all these
transitions we have to go to and I like to call
it like the breaking down of the ego self right to
really get under what it is you really want to do
and I had come back to los angeles gotten divorced
and had two small kids and didn't want to go back
in the movie business I didn't want to go back
and be like a production assistant I had done
that been there done that and I felt I would
probably have to start in the beginning again
and to me just getting a job at
trader joe's just seemed like
it's where it's like somewhere safe for eight
hours to just be a worker among workers which I
really felt I needed to do I honestly did not 100
need the money my ex-husband was working but that
eleven dollars an hour I had not made a paycheck
in a little while and that eleven dollars an hour
was like really special to me oh sorry I remember
when the manager they had reviews I've never been
reviewed in my life I've always been my own boss
and he took me outside and he said kim the one
big note we have for you is it's time for you to
step up to your true potential and I just started
sobbing on a bench in westwood and I think he
was like oh my god because it hit it was so true
that this guy had seen this in me you know and he
was like okay well we're going to give you your 30
cent raise I was like thank you thank you so much
and it it just really made me see how i'd always
been kind of hiding in the shadows so from having
retail jobs myself you know you you interact with
so many people some are wonderful some maybe not
so much but there's always interesting characters
were you watching some of the patrons come in even
though you were busy working I'm sure but yeah
one eye was like you know that would make a great
character right there I didn't really think of
it as like because I was having an experience on
such a personal level like I'm sure in my writing
because I still write I write all the time but
I you know I think that those you know they come
you remember them but at the moment I wasn't like
oh that's a good character like versus when I was
in the film business I was always like that but
now I was just having the experience with people
as it was almost freeing it was like it wasn't
for anything it was just to have the experience
and the people that I worked with there was a
guy who was a you know he had been a convict
and we commiserated over tattoos and I went to his
tattoo guy and there were just there was like a
two guys that were married and like I got to know
them and so just to getting to know there was a
another worker who had lost a baby at like
six months and we would hug every morning
nobody needed to say anything we were just like
two people trying to process and so there was a
lot of that beautiful energy in that store and
then there were the people that would come in
they were the moms who were going to the same
kids went to the same school as my kid down the
street and they would come in and they would like
kind of corner me and they'd be like desperate to
get divorced but they didn't know if they could
financially support themselves so they wanted
to know how I did it I'm like I'm not financially
supporting myself yet on trader joe's but you know
here you know you got to make the leap and you
got to know you know you got to figure it out and
they were just so fascinated by my courage to
work there and there were some very self-entitled
people my daughters love this story there was a
woman who came in now you could do what's called
carryout service where you don't really have to
have a reason you don't have to be handicapped
or anything you can just demand carryout service
right and this woman demanded the carryout service
and as we're as I'm pushing her card she turns
around and looks me and she goes run and I was
like every east coast punky part of me was just
like I am going to tell this woman where to put it
and so instead I just slowed down and I just
got the cart there and I walked back in and
two of my friends at work there were just sort
of waiting for me and they look and they go so
how did that go and I was like oh my god you guys
didn't warn me they're like oh my god we can't
stand that woman and it was like she does that to
everybody she's like we are there for her sure you
know and then there was a couple of a man who got
racially verbally abusive with an iranian woman
and it was like you know she wasn't moving fast
enough this is like the trader joe's I worked at
we would have these peak hours where every
register all eight would be full and you'd
just be so stressed and so then for something
explosive to happen at your station was like it
was just puts you into like a state of shock and
he said something about like you know learn how
to use your card you and he called her a slur name
and she just turns around and she's like I'm an md
and they just started going at it and the manager
had to come over and it was we had some intense
stuff so at that time had you been writing your
memoir or that I had not even come to terms with
i don't think I had even had the dream about
the sexual abuse yet so the memoir is about
waking up and realizing that
I had been sexually abused
for most of my childhood so I had not
woken to that yet I think that was
one year after
and so with dreams you'd always been empathic so
you've always been very sensitive to picking up
I didn't know I was until in the last six years
yeah I've really stepped into that I probably have
been my whole life it's just you can suppress
that stuff and just not even know what that is
until you start kind of being in circles of people
that are empathic that are intuitive that start to
tell you you're psychic you start to see energy
move in the direction in which your thoughts
are empowering it and so I do believe abuse
survivors have an extra dose of that because of
the disassociation right and having to be hyper
aware of their surroundings yeah for survival
right so at what point did you think about writing
what happened did people talk you out of it
I didn't tell anybody I just started doing it like
I just knew that I had to write this book and I
knew that writing the book was the way through
which is what I tell a lot of my book clients
it's like just write the story just work your way
through it just get that first draft down because
what you're going to then share to the reader who
needs you that'll come out in that second draft
once you get it all down so I just wrote and wrote
and wrote and wrote and then later just kind of
readjusted it to like some of the anger or some
of the some some stuff that was a little bit too
journaly I took out just to really so I could I
wanted to put it into categories for people like
explaining how sexual abuse affects every area of
your life sexuality spirituality capacity to make
money masculine and feminine energy everything it
somehow skews your perception in all those areas
and so I just kind of broke it down by the way
I saw my life having been dictated about with
the abuse without even really knowing that's
what was happening did you confront the person
he was dead ah okay yeah okay yeah forgive me if
this is too personal and we can stop if it is did
you talk to other people that may have been around
at that time I did I part of the process was I
called my mom because it was my dad and
received a big dose of I don't I didn't know
there and then called my cousin so I've been close
with growing up and actually called not both I
actually only called one of the three cousins
who I who I'm more close to and he was just
so sympathetic and devastated and no nobody denied
it you know told my one aunt his mom and tried to
tell my sister she didn't want to hear it it's
just so interesting your family like who will
you know my daughter my teenage
daughter who's now 15 and a half
I'm not going to beat myself up about it but I
did tell her fairly young I think she was 12 or 13
as old as my current 12 year old is now who knows
nothing and I think cause she was the first born
it was sort of like you look at them as more
ready to handle it she came to a book signing
and she went through a lot of fear for a little
while about the legacy of our family she was
afraid of like how it was going to be carried
down even though there's no we've already broken
the legacy there's no abuse in our structure
so it's one of those things I learned like we
need to empower our children but they're still
it's still like it's still a very scary subject
for for young people can you talk about
making decisions from high self-esteem versus
low self-esteem sure I think now the decisions
that I make are you know really looking at like
what I want as in the bigger picture versus the
data like everything used to be so important
day to day like the outcome of what you know the
voices in my head and what they would say you know
like oh you didn't do that right or you didn't
make enough money or that person's not happy or
I can't change anybody's opinion I can't make
anybody happy and I can't necessarily make
anybody sad unless I've done something erroneous
which I could apologize for but the higher the
higher self-esteem is definitely from that place
of more thinking I'm good like I've got this like
I'm on the higher ground like I know where I'm
going like the world everything that I want is
already available to me versus before and this
was a lot in the movie business just a lot of just
financial chaos you know fearing being you know
like criticized or just not being enough you know
I don't feel that way now and do you think a large
part of it has to do with the dream and sort of
coming clean with your past even though it
was no fault of your own but just realizing
what happened and what you had suppressed oh
yeah I i think when you've been abused there's a
natural feeling that you're damaged goods and that
like you're dirty right and you and especially if
you haven't faced it you just are like confused
while you're why you're why you feel different
you know inside and a lot of abuse survivors turn
to drugs and alcohol to just because it's just
some there's something wrong but they don't know
what it is right so you're in the unknown where
for some people I mean even now the unknown can
be like oh my god but like you're in the unknown
and it's like it's almost like you're dying
it's that painful right because you're you're
untethered to something right like you might
not be tethered to the abuser anymore but you're
you're in there if you don't have faith
then you're not tethered there so drugs and
alcohol are a great great way for you to feel
powerful because you're making a decision to
do something I'm gonna get messed up and I'm gonna
be messed up and that's a clear cut decision and
outcome where everything else really involves
other people and you can also hang out with other
people like-minded that are want to do it too
right oh yeah it's a very social thing oh yeah
yeah in my 30s I hung out with just just just
terrible people that did all sorts of drugs
and I don't know if they had any abuse in
their history I'm probably I mean they were
it was again it was like oh we're filmmakers
that's what filmmakers do they do a lot of
and then it just is not just doesn't work anymore
I'm comedian I mean I you know when when I moved
back when I moved to la and in my 30s like
when I first got this whole thing going in la
there were a lot of just people that were
doing a lot of drugs do you think that's
why the trader joe's experience was also because
you felt you could just be yourself whereas with
the mom's group you had to be something right
you couldn't you didn't want to scare a mom
you know with who I really was right they could
be the same way but right they didn't want to
have that out go there it's true trader joe's we
were just all a bunch of misfits it was so so true
and I feel most comfortable I I'm i'm someone
that can kind of get along with everybody
but I'm always going to have a little bit
of like a I like people with a little bit
more of like a edge you know that like the thing
kind of thing like we can laugh about the way we
think and it's a little nutty and we don't have
to be too apologetic because life is just life
and yeah I don't do well with a
lot of like surficial relationships
and were you like that before the memoir
or or that's yes but in a very angry way
so there was a lot of anger you know like why am
I feeling like this all the time there's a lot of
yelling I have a whole section in the book where I
talk about the rage and how you're just constantly
just yelling at people and you don't know why
and you don't know what's behind all that rage
right and and movies were a great place for that
because again it was justified I'm painting such
a horrible picture of the movie business I loved
making movies by the way and there were a lot of
beautiful people and I had a lot of great
experiences but for me it was a it was you
it was okay for you to scream at somebody where
now I'm like that's completely unacceptable if
I'm even snippy with someone on my team now
I apologize I send them like a coffee card
but maybe that you know maybe it is maybe it is
I think it's I think it has to do with recovery
from abuse I think you do start to see and you
stu you do start to feel what it feels like hurt
people hurt people so if you're not hurt
anymore you're not really wanting to hurt
anybody anymore and then I think you start to
evolve on the other side of like well if I'm not
a hurt person then who am I actually going
to be a girlfriend of mine wrote a tv show
and this was seven years ago when I was just
kind of I had been substitute teaching and I had
written my book I was starting to kind of get get
my feet going and you know I don't think i'd even
written my book yet but i'd come to terms with
the abuse and she asked me to produce a pilot
and I was like I'm not gonna produce a pilot like
I'm not going back into the business and she's
no we're gonna have a great time and i'll pay
you it'll be really fun and and I was like okay
and I was newly newly I had stopped drinking so
I was clean as a whistle and I was like all right
it's worth it and then someone said to me when
the job was done and we had we had a great time
and when the job was done someone said to me you
know why don't you poll the people that worked for
you and ask them what they thought of you and I
was like so moved that not a single person called
me a yeller no one said I was aggressive they said
when I came in the room they knew help was here
that I made them laugh that I was always the last
one to leave and I was like what and I knew that
something big had changed in my life and then
I thought oh I want to make a movie like this
it's the one thing I kind of wish that I could
make a movie as the new me because I would
show up on that film set very differently very
differently than I would have back then it would
I would have fun what's the inciting incident in
your book it would be waking up from the dream
absolutely and sitting in my living room
and really thinking oh I know and then
what do I do now that's the inciting incident
there's a whole journey that comes from that
and and most people like clients
that I work with in their books
it's usually that that one t it's not always like
the most exciting moment necessarily it's that
that inside moment where you know
something's going to change forever
and it did when you went to sleep the night
before had you watched a movie did something
happen do you think triggered it or no it was
just this time why did you procrastinate writing
for so long I know you had this realization but
didn't weren't there other things you were putting
off yeah I mean I think that I had to go through a
lot of different experiences so that I could know
what to write about so if I had just started
writing right away from the dream and I was I
was journaling everything so I had a lot of good
material but I hadn't lived enough yet to really
see the difference right so like I had to be a
recovered sort of I had to be a survivor for a
little while before I felt like I could really
look at what I had slighted myself in in living
to write about what I could potentially
have and my second book which is written
and it's sitting on my laptop is all about the
next steps which is you've put in a bunch of
years as a survivor you've seen the change and
you're ready to leave behind that past of how
you used to live and you're ready to kind of now
take this new you into another level of your life
but I am procrastinating on it I've decided I want
to write another book that's a lot more fun so
that can happen sometimes and get distracted but
I do believe everything is in the right time so
I know that my first book got published so I know
that another one will and I've actually taken that
book down the first memoir I took the rights back
from the publisher in december I don't feel like
the service was done that it deserves people read
it and they go this is like the most amazing book
I've ever read on abuse this should be a worldwide
book and the publisher did not do a good job so
and neither did I frankly because today you have
to be behind your book 100 you can't rely on a
publisher at all and so I've taken the book rights
back I'm actually doing a second edition on it
I'm going to rename it and I'm going to
put it out under my own publishing label
why rename it kicking abuse
in the ass was a very sort of
yeah kind of title right and I want it to reach
more people so now I'm going to call it awoken
okay are you do you think the title might scare
certain people I i want to go more direct I think
what I've learned with my clients and helping them
come up with book titles and and chapter headings
there's like there's a there's a fine line
between clever and kind of not really telling
people what you're going to do for them
in the book like kicking abuse in the ass
it wasn't really what I was doing in the book
100 it wasn't like I was going in there and
slaying it I was really being reflective
why do you think most writers procrastinate
oh a whole I could give you the longest list I
hear I've heard everything from I'm afraid of
being famous what will I do with all my time
when I'm famous how am I going to take care
I don't want to upset my family members I don't
know if I can finish something I've started
so they don't even start I'm not I don't have a
writing degree like I don't have like a you know a
I'm not a graduate of the iowa state
writing you know writing conference so
why bother a lot of a lot of reasons a lot
of reasons I can't find time on my schedule
I don't understand what kind of support I need I
don't know what kind of structure there should be
a million reasons you had talked about you were
looking to maybe one day direct write and direct
as the new kim what what you saw as the new kim
do you think people don't know what the new self
would be as this author if that like you talked
about this fear of being famous whatever but also
too they'd be taking on this new persona that
maybe they'd be leaving victimhood or whatever
behind and now can you talk about that oh yeah new
persona and how you transformed into that I love
that this question is such a beautiful question
because it comes up actually more in the class
I run called own your authorship where it's sort
of that chasm between like they have the desire
to tell their story but the yes feels like kind
of far you know and people come in and they they
take the class and they're like a little bit like
who are you and who do you you know a little bit
like not chip on their shoulder but you
know let's see what you got you know
and I just work them till you know we turn we
do a prompt that's called I hate you because and
many people write about themselves and then I
make them go back and write it about someone else
and they go well I don't want to hate
somebody else I go well you know you do
so why don't you tell us about it like if
you're going to get honest get honest now
we're not going to email it to them just write it
and I think that that's where they start to unlock
and they start to see themselves and and start
to be okay and then they just really like you
see a shift immediately where there's they're
realizing wait a minute like I have a story to
tell and then we do you know come find a picture
of yourself in your 20s some groups i'll do
little kids like i'll kind of intuitively
gauge the group I can tell very early on
what I need to do with people I'm very intuitive
that way and from that writing about where they
came from you just see them start to just like
light up and then we talk about the author persona
and what is your author persona like who would
you be if you were like a successful author what
does that look like would you have your own jet
are you doing a book tour worldwide or is this
where you make all your income and you see a lot
of them like well I don't know I mean is that part
we're not saying that's gonna happen or not happen
I just want you to write about it you know and so
a lot of the resistance is the it's almost
like they feel like they're saying something
that's not true by writing about it even though
it's a dream they have so if you can get them
to write about the dream then the dream suddenly
doesn't seem so far-fetched what do you think your
biggest resistance was to writing I think for
me a lot of it was time I was single parenting
trying to build a business and I literally did not
have any time I also did not hire a coach which I
should have done when I finally hired an editor
everything moved really fast because I was ready
but I think I just I i you know I didn't take my
own medicine you know I didn't bring in someone
I was telling everybody that my clients how
important it is to be coachable and I wasn't co
being coached so i'd say my resistance was I
didn't think that I was worthy of exactly what
I tell my clients to believe they're worthy of how
do you know you have the right coach so I'm sure
there's a gazillion coaches editors out there
you know there's not a lot of book coaches that
necessarily do a white glove service I don't hear
about a lot of them I hear about you know editors
that might edit your book over 90 days or and
I'm doing more of like a deep dive into like
the whole purview of the person like what do you
want to what does this book mean to you like what
do you want to be with this book like I often
help people come up with trademarkable systems or
business ideas or mantras that they can actually
then claim as their own through the writing of
the book that they couldn't see before i'll be
like that's brilliant nobody else is doing that
and they'll be like oh my god yeah so I'm not sure
that that's so much of just an editor I think that
is definitely more of a coach because I'm seeing
the human potential in that person through what
they're sharing with me about who they are and
then we happen to be writing a book through it all
so is this someone who already has a first draft
finish I don't take people typically on that have
a first draft because then we'd have to break it
all up and then I'm just putting glue on something
that's probably broken so I like to work with
people from the very very start so if I call you
and say or email you and say I would like to write
about my life I don't even have an outline I'm
just telling you this is my desire and we're going
to go from there and structure it together yep wow
yeah that's that's my favorite way to work because
we really just start from this from scratch
you know we do the outline together and then we go
through eight months of work what are some of the
first questions you ask someone it really depends
on the people I mean I don't have a formula
more than outline day first draft second
draft third draft get the book published
i ask them a lot of questions before I
do the outline day with them and kind
of ask them about you know tell me about three
amazing moments in your life you know write to
me about what you think about yourself what
were some of your greatest accomplishments
if they've told me a little bit about
something that happened in their life
or why they became a coach or why they've been
a binge eater or you know what it was like in
the navy i'll say give me a couple scenes on
that because from that I can sort of get a tone
of what it would be and then and a lot of that is
movie business work you know kind of seeing what
the scenes are and then wrapping around the scenes
a narrative for the book do you ever ask them the
why yeah we do that knowing your authorship
we work out the why generally because people
that are not ready to write a book the reason
is because they're not confident in their why
so that's why I have them take the class people
that come to be ready to be a private client
they're pretty rock they've got a really good why
it might be a little bit smaller than they think
like i'll find a bigger why but generally
they come in with like this is what I'm
writing about and I don't have to like work it
so these aren't wishy-washy people on the fence
they're they're like there's no people that do
my one year now there's not a lot of convincing
I like to say like if someone comes to me for
a one year they're usually like there's no cell
they're just in but if I'm on the phone
with someone for a really long time
then generally they're not going to be a client
right away do you talk to your clients about if
they write something traumatic what they may feel
physically oh yeah I've had clients go down for
the count for a couple weeks just pure exhaustion
of just sort of reliving something or realizing
putting the patterns together there's
there's some dismay there's some anger
you know we feel so much in our bodies as
creatives and sometimes they're connecting
to themselves in that way for the first time and
so some things are kicked off if they have like
you know an autoimmune or something like that I
don't do like a medical intake form but I will
you know I kind of gauge it as we go like I won't
I don't want to scare them and then put on them
someone else's experience like oh such and such
wrote about such and such and she was out for the
count like because they might not be that person
they might muscle through but I i do watch for it
did that happen to you yeah I right after the and
it hadn't it wasn't the writing yet so this is
another reason why I was delayed with the book
right after I came to terms with the abuse I
got an autoimmune disorder called echolatia
and that's in like 1 in 200 000 people and
it's literally your voice so it's just too it's
just too like connected to discount it but it
I you asked the question about the high you
know the high self-worth and the low self-worth
because I was so I took care of myself
like I took care of myself on all like this
but inside of me I hadn't taken care of myself in
so long that I just thought for like nine months
that I was having like jerred or like
some kind of like regurgitation I was
having a lot of regurgitation and I was
getting skinnier and skinnier and skinnier
and I remembered and then I couldn't eat and then
I went to see my regular doctor and I walked into
her office and she the look on her face when she
saw me and she said have you looked in the mirror
at yourself and she dragged me over to the
mirror and I had like an abscess on my chin
I was gaunt my and she did all these labs and my
blood was attacking me and they literally had to
find a specialist with appalachia within two weeks
and I was in a massive surgery in three weeks
and so that it's an autoimmune disorder and it
was brought out I think it was brought out I
think it was probably always suppressed but I
think when you just open up sometimes you're
gonna get the good and sometimes you're gonna get
the ugly and that was definitely an ugly situation
so how long did that keep you debilitated for that
was I mean the recovery from it was pretty quick
once they do the surgery you're you're better like
you're better in five days but just like getting
my system back going you know when your body has
an intake hasn't taken in any food really for
a long time everything has to re-wake up so it's
kind of symbolic everything started waking up plus
you get into this and a lot of women talk about
this like getting better is not getting skinny
so I had kind of fallen into this whole
I'm skinny and then when my body started
course correcting back to what I should
be there was a lot of like oh my god like
I'm getting fatter and I didn't sign up for
this and so there was a lot of looking at
you know the pluses and minuses of
my story like when am I gonna be kim
for real and then that started to catch up
and that's about when I started write the book
what is a memoir a memoir is writing about
people's their lives and something that they've
experienced that they think is extraordinary and
if you think about a classic one the glass castle
which was about a woman who just had
this horrendous childhood and she's
looking back at it from being I think she was very
successful in business so you almost can't believe
what she had been through to get to where she was
it's just a retelling of it's a retelling of your
life and there's a new sort of hybrid that's
kind of crept into the marketplace and that's
the self-help piece in the memoir and that's
all you know I don't I wouldn't say my book is
as much memoir as it is self-help because I'm not
taking you to the past I'm staying pretty much in
a small c like a microcosm of adulthood
I'm not talking about my childhood at all
so your your recount your your adult
kim thinking back having this dream
sharing with the reader waking up and the
realization and then looking back at sort of
my adult life why I behaved the way I behaved in
my adult life there's nothing we can do about any
of it anyway going back to the childhood is not
going to necessarily give me any answers except
for like the original self right which you were
when the day you were born and then from there on
it started to get messed with anyway so I didn't
have a lot of memories of I didn't want to write a
tell-all about abuse my situation was not violent
and it wasn't like particularly traumatic it was
almost like a continuing dream of events that
would come up in my memory and I would think
oh that was odd that day we went down that dirt
why did we go down that dirt road but that was
it like my mind was not wanting me to know more
than that and so I made the decision that it would
serve my reader better if I focused on what I
feel the abuse had created for me as problems
and what I was starting to become had you read a
lot of other memoirs I know you mentioned the one
before but no you hadn't no I think there's one
called like they call me dave or whatever there's
some really great yeah about people remembering
yeah I hadn't read any I didn't want to have any
anybody's else's you know experience to
affect my journey so you didn't want to
sort of mimic the writing style yeah and I and
I tend to with writers who are writing memoirs
I might give them a memoir to read but I often
will give them books on writing to read or
something that would not be like at all in their
category necessarily because I don't want to put
that on them like I don't want them to start
judging their book against this other book
what are some of those writing books that you give
them writing down the bones by natalie goldberg
is like an amazing writer it's like
probably the best book about writing memoir
anything ann and lamont writes is just just rita
and lamont I mean for her wit and her use of
description and the way she just sort of moves
the narrative along the war of art is another
phenomenal book I'm forgetting his name right
now stephen pressfield steven pressfield that is
an excellent book there was a book called
how to read as a new york times writer or
author and I'm not remembering her name but it's
literally like she broke down every book that's
great to read by if you want to learn about
voice if you want to learn about structure
if you want to learn about narrative
if you want to learn about flashback
and I remember one point in time I got
the book and I read them I read everything
and just reading we we don't read enough
and you become a better writer when you read
yeah anne lamott's ted talk is great
too you know she she puts a lot of humor
yeah and she's very very easy to relate to
yeah and yeah bay area personally yep she is
do you think it's important for
anyone who wants to write a book
to begin writing a memoir is that the first step
to writing a book or if someone wants to write
a narrative that's you mean like fiction or oh
I think anybody should write whatever they want
to write if you don't want to write a memoir
don't write a memoir because it's definitely a
very specific style of book if you want to write a
psychological thriller you know learn how to write
a psychological thriller if you want to learn how
to you know write a like and lamont like journal
sort of witty repartee kind of book write that and
there's you know different classes you can take in
those specific areas for me I can coach anybody
because I'm not specifically a writing teacher
right so I'm not going to come in and teach
you how to be a better psychological thriller
writer I'm going to help you have a better
writer voice for you but I'm not necessarily
an expert in the psychological thriller I might
be an expert on great characters or a great plot
so sometimes people ask me that they're like well
there seems to be like a formula with certain
books and I'm like wow is there I don't know
because I'm that's not my genre what are some
common mistakes you see new writers make that
once they're at a professional level you don't
see as much so what would so professional levels
an interesting term because what would that be
I mean I i say to my clients the minute you've
made a decision to write a book you are now a
professional author and you need to think that way
and if you have to take a post-it and you have to
put it on your desk that says I am a professional
author or I am an author you need to do that you
need to put it everywhere in your house until you
actually believe that you are of the same quality
as anybody else there's no like distinction
between you and the person who's super famous
or as a new york times bestseller you have to own
that within you first and I think once they step
to that then it's really just it's time to work on
the craft and there's certain writers that take to
this the art of writing like a duck to water
they will take direction really quickly they'll
you know they're not afraid of us doing a first
draft and then me saying okay let's rip it apart
because the middle of the book should be where
we start the book and this c this chapter should
mix with this chapter and I think we might need a
different ending because that's what happens when
you do the first draft the second draft is really
where the magic happens there are some people that
are not afraid of that they're like let's they
roll up there let's let's do it and there's other
people that are like oh my god what does that mean
like we just I just did this for like 12 weeks now
you're gonna we're gonna rip it apart what is that
and there's a lot more fear of the process right
which is understandable because they just did
a process that they were not comfortable with
they just they're like oh phew I just got through
that and now we have oh there's another process
but inevitably everybody at the end of the second
draft sees the light at the end of the tunnel no
matter where they were in the first draft they're
all like this is good some are more like a little
bit like we're on to something and other other
people are like oh my god this is like so excited
like this is magic like magic has happened so I
think by the end of the second draft they all kind
of feel like professional writers some of them
might hang on a little bit to they might start
to as it gets closer to like going out and looking
for a publisher well do you think my writing is
good like are you sure it's up to standard do you
think my writing is good enough and you know it's
just assurance it's like it's not that you're
right it's not whether your writing is right
or wrong it's are you communicating in a clear
entertaining and effective way something that's
going to inspire the reader and drive them to
take some kind of action in their life right like
maybe you're you're you're espousing some
kind of new philosophy have you done a good
enough job having them actually sit up and
go I never thought about that I'm gonna I'm
gonna change the way I do that in my life
which is what a lot of great books will do
why would someone be afraid to go through the
first draft whereas others are like yeah let's
do it rip it apart like tell me the truth I think
just that that there's that there is a banality
even there's like a conflict right so on one hand
they've been told for years by everybody under the
sun you should write a book and so they believe
and then there's underneath a little part of them
that believes that right but they're coming in
a little bit driven on external forces right so
they'll come in and they'll be like okay well
I'm gonna do it kind of because everybody else
said I should do it and I kind of believe I
should do it so I'm gonna write this thing
but there's in the back of their mind still
that like self-defeating mindset that's like
and it's often can be a voice that
says who cares does this really matter
like you're spending all this time and energy
like putting this out because what the valet
said you should write a story because your
aunt mary said you should write a story
I don't know this seems like a lot of time and
a lot of you're spending a lot of time with that
kim lady how do you even know she's qualified
like what even are her credentials and I joke
about this sometimes when I do talks about what
that voice will do to try to keep you safe right
because you've been safe you've gotten so far
your ego's like we're cool we're good and all of
a sudden you're like but I actually want to tell
them that he goes like no wait a minute we've been
good without you telling all these stories
why do you want to upset the apple cart now
so that's more what I see coming into play and
it comes in all different ways it comes in tiers
it comes in argumentativeness it comes in you know
I see it all I have a lot of very strong willed
personality clients and I see it
come out in all different ways
what about a third draft oh the third draft is
just heaven because we've ripped it apart we've
put it back together we know exactly what the
book is and now we get to do like a lot of bells
and whistles so maybe we didn't find a system
in the book that we knew would have to be there
I used my client alan maxwell a lot for this
example he had written a a memoir about his
life from philadelphia to becoming a top defense
contractor in san diego in the navy in between
and we were done with the third draft and I
said we've done a beautiful book we've done
a beautiful job this is someone who knew nothing
about writing and dictated most of his book and
we had to like do a lot of fixing on it but
got it done in the airport on a busy schedule
and I said this is a beautiful book
we've done a great job but who cares
and he looked at me and he went what do you mean
who cares and I said how are we gonna make this
something that stands out amid all the other
people that thought that they should write a
memoir because he's not famous and I said every
time you write something you talk about a system
that you've been in whether it's various parts
of the navy or parts of society in georgia or
the government and I said you've got some rules
that you've applied in your life to get through
those situations that you've then carried into new
situations how many do you think you might have of
those rules he said I don't know let me go let
me go figure it out so we came up with 15 rules
we then went back through the book on a fourth
draft found all the places the rules would apply
and put them into the book and he became
a wall street journal top 10 business book
wow so we went from great this is your life it's
very interesting but who are you and why should we
be dialed in to then you tapped into that a lot
of rules structures things interesting yeah and we
made it something that was for anybody like we had
a 17 year old girl read it and she was just blown
away yeah she was like I would take this as my
book that I would bring out into the world and use
because if you think about it anytime we step into
anywhere if you have these tips that he gives and
you understand these rules apply and you're savvy
with them you can figure out who your allies are
who your enemies are you know you can figure out
you can keep your eyes open and attuned to certain
certain situations see the red flags you're going
to do pretty well interesting so was it was it
too vanilla before or it was still interesting but
he wasn't giving the reader anything exactly okay
and so is that something that could be as we
all think our lives are fascinating and okay
they won't make a movie about me but maybe
if I write my book they'll they'll right
right but but is is that what sometimes we're
missing is what are we offering the reader
what are we offering the reader and he actually
has some discreet chapters that are standalone
movies without a doubt I mean he has you know
uss destroyers getting song I mean he has very
exciting moments but that wasn't enough right it's
great to read that that adds to his credibility
with his knowledge that he's sharing but
standalone it wasn't a hundred percent enough
when people come to me write memoirs I do say what
do you think of your like core areas that you have
the the golden thread or the line of
something your whole life you've kind of
not paid attention to so it might be
money messaging from childhood and then
money chaos money chaos money chaos money
chaos till finally they changed something
and now they might not still be great with
money but they they're free right and then all
the scenes support that through line someone
could read that and see their money stories
and see their pattern and so it's like they they
they are able to have like some kind of epiphany
or recovery or learning curve through being
entertained in that narrative how do you know
when a writer is holding back so let's say I bring
to you what I think is a traumatic scene and you
read it and you say yeah it sounds traumatic but
I'm not like it's missing something's missing here
when they write more about okay so when they write
more about the other person in the scene than them
that's how I know they're holding back they're
not talking about themselves they're taking that
other person's inventory and it's more about
that other person so i'll say well this isn't
a book about that person how did you feel in
that situation that's a number one example
you can actually see it before they even
start writing the book typically they'll
a client will come to me this isn't I don't mean
typically in this situation this is how it unfolds
I've got all this other writing that I've done and
i'd love for you to read it all because I think
I want to include it all in the book and i'll go
well how much of their of it is there and they'll
say well I mean it's like a couple short stories I
wrote I think there might be some nuggets in there
and I think oh we're never going to use any of
this but I think well i'll read it right because
I'm getting to know them and it's it's it's almost
like part of the process because they're saying to
me this is who I was before I came to you will you
look at me right so they are actually giving me an
opportunity to see where they're going to have to
go from and i'll read the material and i'll either
i'll glean from it they are this kind of
writer or this is what's been important to them
we never use that material because I see that
they're going to like I see I get a good idea
I'm like okay this is I understand where they're
starting from I understand why they're coming to
me I understand why they're showing me
this they're saying and a lot of times
the material will have pretty graphics in it
and they've spent a lot of time presenting it
when they write books with me I'm like do not put
any graphics in the book while we're writing it
it's just something we have to delete move around
it's just it's technical stuff words just words
don't dressing it up is not gonna change my edit
notes like I'm gonna come I'm not you're not gonna
like fool me with the pictures right and so
that's one way that I see that they might be
like a little more resistant to being honest I
had a client once who wrote an entire book with me
for two drafts and it was at
the end of the second draft
I don't I don't know if I missed it or she just
threw it in kind of like slid it in but it I read
it and I realized that something had happened
to her as a baby in a crib it was abuse and
she hadn't even realized and she
didn't even realize she'd written it
and that was that was painful that was that was it
was it was it was hard to call it out and it was
hard for her to process it so I think if you want
to tell it'll come out right whether you know it
or not whether you know it or not the words kind
of they don't lie that'll be the truth it's like
freudian slips very true how common is it for a
writer to not believe in themselves I mean does
anybody ever really believe in themselves who's
a that are that is a writer I mean I have days
I think I think it varies from day to day I i
think that one thing I've been doing lately is
I'm part of a writing group and we will write
and read out loud and nobody will say anything
you just read and it's thank you and then another
part of that group which is more of an advanced
group we will read a chapter and then the group
will comment on it and I think that that takes
away when you're able to present and perform you
get out of that headspace that I'm all alone and
on any given day it's all about me I'm either
good or I'm bad good or bad it's hardly ever
well that was a good day it's it's never in
the middle yes I think as a writer you're
either [ __ ] or you're amazing so when you are
in a group and you're reading to other people
you realize that there's a lot of good things
about your writing there's some things that
need to be fixed about your writing oh I didn't
expect that person would like that oh I really
like how I sounded oh wow I'm writing about all
these gosh I keep using that voice wow I'm really
snarky there's so many other things to think about
versus good or bad and that's where I try to get
writers to work from like what are your strengths
what are some of the areas you could improve
if that's not something you're very interested in
getting better then maybe we'll have someone come
in and do maybe like some edits on that for you
or you know but rarely does anyone say oh I'm not
I'm not a good writer I think they're pretty
pretty proud of themselves by the time they
get through three drafts if anything they're very
proud of the work they just did week after week
there was the the vigilance and the resiliency
no matter what to sit down at that computer and
write a chapter even if it's something they want
to just throw against the wall in absolute disgust
you know I've had them turn in chapters and
and say well I'm turning it in dot dot dot
you're like you know the rest of that sentence
is but I think it's terrible and it never is
what about the flip side those that
think it's amazing and actually
maybe they're not seeing themselves and
I mean it's they're blinded by something
that's a great question I do no experience
I have had experiences like that where
they're on a journey and you could
all you can just be their guide so
you can tell that a lot of what they're writing
probably belongs in a journal and might need
some more extensive therapy before it goes out in
the world it's definitely a little bit of a dump
maybe a little bit of a [ __ ] show
but that's not my I'm not a I'm not to judge their
experience so if they're done with it and they say
and I might say this felt a little hard are you
sure you want to come out and say that about like
your mom or that ex-husband or like you know
I know we're going to change some names but
that just was that's whoa that's real you're
going for the jugular on that one I know
that's who they're going to be and I don't I am
I am you know hats off to you like I've given
the disclaimer because what will happen is is
that they'll go out and try to sell the book
and a lot of times with a little
bit of my guidance depending on
whether they're still coaching with me or not
but they'll go out and I've become friends with
most of these people at this point so I am I
have a lot invested emotionally with them but
they'll find out sooner or later
because someone will say this feels like
an emotional dump and then they'll have to go
you know maybe I should like get rid of that
one scene with the you know and some people
need more of a rewrite and they don't have
time or money anymore to do a rewrite so
they might have to sit on it for a while
so if it feels really heavy if I'm like whoa
this is not I'm not moved but this is almost like
uncomfortable for me then maybe it is this dump
is is that how yeah it's not really for the reader
it's for the writer still and you want to get
it to a place where it's for the reader to then
have their experience and feel like I just heard
someone say that like angela's ashes he wrote that
for 10 years or something because he wanted to
write it until he wasn't angry anymore so that
the experience could be for the reader what is
your process for coaching belief into someone
well I always just say the fact that they signed
up for a one-year program and they're showing up
every week is already pretty amazing and really
impressive I'm always giving like positive notes
like love or that was amazing or look how
you turned that around or this is incredible
in my one year program there isn't a lot of time
to not believe in yourself it's so rigorous and
it's so continual that I don't really think
it's belief that trips them up because once
they start getting going they just want to do
the work and finish it because they're committed
I think belief falls more into people that aren't
there yet right so that would be more in the own
your authorship class that's people who you
know it's a lot more like cheerleading and
a lot more showing them the light of the vision
that they have that they can get to the finish
line that they are worthy of writing that they
just they deserve you know they they can have
that desire as much as anybody else can have that
desire so there's a lot more coaching belief in
I would say the in those early early
foundational and fundamental classes
but my one-year clients they're pretty badass
they they signing up for a one-year program
and and and putting out twenty thousand
dollars you already better believe
because you're invested does anyone get scared
because they know people will read it and they may
identify they may even though names are changed
and think but they're just afraid even you know
yeah it's traumatic to divulge secrets I've had
clients sit on their books for a little bit longer
than I thought they should have but that was their
process that they needed to go through and then
when they did actually release the book they were
ready and so they're ready you know when they're
ready or they had to like the book had shown
them something about themselves and so they had
to go be with that new self for a little while
and then maybe start a podcast or open another
version of their business and they knew the book
was good so it's not like it was getting stale
they knew that they could bring it out when they
felt like they were in a in a successful space
and so sometimes that might be
six months after they're done
after a year I start to to hassle them what
happened to your book what happened to your
book what happened to your book and some
people it doesn't happen much anymore but in
my early days of coaching there were people
that wrote the book just to write the book
they were done they were like I'm good something
I wanted to do in retirement I don't really think
I have time and energy to go through the whole
publishing process I'm really happy I did it I
feel like I wanted it down on paper for legacy
and I just don't think I need to publish it
sometimes I've seen comments that when someone's
written about let's say a famous parent
that whatever the public's perception of that
individual is they end up getting mad at the at
the writer because maybe they're divulging things
that we don't want to see that side of that person
right have you ever talked about you know the the
criticism that could come for divulging secrets
or speaking about whatever oh yeah isn't seen as
honoring whomever I like to say if you're getting
that kind of criticism you're doing well with your
book because nobody criticizes a book nobody cares
about so I believe to get that level of criticism
you have to have a lot of eyeballs on your book
a lot of eyeballs on your book to kind of
kick up that kind of you know dissent about it
right that many people have to be reading
it so I i look at that as kind of a win it's
like good they're fired up tell more people to
read it because they're going to be fired up
and they're going to be upset and I haven't
had anybody write about anybody famous um
i do have a client who wrote about a
lot of there were hollywood people in
it she hasn't published yet but she wasn't
she was like that's the way it went down
and I was there so it's not like contestable
really because it's exactly what happened
and there were witnesses so you know we don't
like in general our bubbles burst if that
if that's the bubble it's going to be burst for
you and you chose that book to read it maybe you
were looking to get that bubble burst anyway
you just don't know it on a subconscious level
what are five steps to writing a bad book only
talking about yourself without a a purpose
or a mission of something that you want to have
the reader experience like joy or a journey or
an emotional release I'm talking
more in memoir and self-help using
language like it and this and maybe
and perhaps in like kind of vague
terms instead of rewriting the sentences
every sentence should be a thing of beauty
it's a book take your time to make every line
matter don't just think well those sentences
were good these can be kind of a slough off
rewrite every make every sentence beautiful
um don't aim low don't decide I'm just going to
write an ebook and give it away for free on your
website I don't think that's not really a book
honor books they're boundable they're thicker
it's something you want to hand to someone and be
proud of not some door stop or something I'm going
to use to balance my computer that's four and
five would be write one draft and then publish it
why would someone do that people do it all the
time they're like that was brilliant nailed it in
one shot and they just discount the whole process
that that was just the beginning you read it you
can tell you can tell when someone's published for
you you don't see that in profession professional
but you see that in you know when I was in like
networking groups or like you know first started
my business people would write books in 90 days or
whatever and you're like I don't want to read it
please don't give me your book this is what I
would be thinking because it would just be fluffy
it would spin it where they were
it was too positive or no it just
wouldn't have you can't I mean
to really dig in and write a
memoir in a short period of time
I don't think it's got enough heft
it hasn't been expanded enough
maybe to write a book about
dating like 101 tips to date
you might be able to do that in the first
draft or 10 tips to good sales calls
you might be able to do that in one draft
but I don't tend to work with those books
when you read an author's work and they write
about themselves in too positive a light
how do you break that down because we've all read
books where oh yeah it was written by this ceo or
this person and they're just telling their grand
vision and it paints them as the saint whereas
when you read about a third party writing about
that same individual it's much juicier it's a full
person warts and all so how do you when you see
somebody's being too pollyanna about themselves
how do you say are we really getting
honest here I don't ever get that
I don't ever get that I think that there's a
lot of self-deprecation in the clients that come
to me I think that they've been through enough
of the rough road that self-deprecation is not
it's not so far from them and if anything
we're trying to get them to be more positive
about themselves and and see where
their beautiful gifts are and see how
what they've written about and what they've
been through inform so much about who they are
i don't I can't think of one experience
where someone just wants to write
about their positive experiences I mean I have had
those conversations where people have called me
and they're like well I'm gonna write a book about
and I and I feel like kind of a cynic going but
where's the darkness right especially when they
say well there really isn't anything dark about
my story and I think oh I don't know if that's
possible who wants to read it where did you live
yeah would you say a lot of new writers write
books that are mediocre or have no essence
no not at all I mean I think it's I think
everybody's a new writer on any project you
start I'm a new writer even though I've
been writing since I was 12 years old
anytime you take on a new narrative or a new group
of characters or maybe a new style of writing or
you're going into new territory you're new you
know you might have more of a bag of tools with
you you might know better paragraph structure
you might do better bridges in and out of your
chapters you might know not to bring in too many
characters in the whole kitchen sink you might
have your themes broken down your why broken
down and your bigger message and you know who
you're writing for and you know what you're
an expert in but you're still new it's still
a fresh slate you're still gonna have all the
same butterflies in your stomach you're still
gonna have all the same you know disembarking on
this like amazing journey and I always say books
are a journey not a destination you're really
not ever really getting anywhere even like
you're you're in a journey like if you get there
the journey's over what books should continue
forever explain to me what a bridge is between
chapel a bridge is leading out of one chapter
into the next chapter so it it either summarizes
and concludes the the first the chapter that's
just ending and leads you into the next chapter
with a flow so you don't feel just that one
chapter ends and then the next chapter starts
there's some kind of with fiction it's a little
bit different especially if you're jumping around
locations but there is some kind of there's a
there's a skill involved in leading the reader
in through like a tapestry of the chapters and
that's what the bridges do and that's really what
we do in the third draft as we work on the bridges
how can you tell a story is boring or it's
wandering what tips do you have to like you said
with the one gentleman who had an interesting
career but it needed it needed these 15 tips
I like people to write their story first first
draft before I start killing their babies is what
I the way I call it and that's I get pretty brutal
like i'll start to go through and just be like
why do we care and who's this for and what
does this do and why do we need this and if
I get some pushback i'll listen because there
could be something that isn't really be being
said and we'll have sometimes like a debate about
it like well what do you mean that the the the
that you say that this is about that character's
evolution I don't see any evolution here at all
I see or just washing dishes in the kitchen with
their grandmother where's the evolution well the
grandmother threw the thing and well you didn't
write that the grandmother threw the thing you
just wrote oh then they go and write it and
it's now a scene that almost is like required
so you don't try to you don't try to throw it you
might have entire storylines that just go right
because sometimes it seems all seems relevant
on the first draft and then in the second draft
we don't need everybody to know every single
part of your life we just need the parts that
serve the themes that are running through
and if that chunk does not serve the theme
they're not going to know the difference whether
you kept it out or not because they don't know you
they only know what you're going to tell them you
want them to know so if we're like oh grandpa john
he would make these great birdhouses and he's
just no do we is grandpa john necessary right
to the story oh he was a really cool guy he
was I would we would watch these no no is he
necessary right no grandpa john's gone sorry yeah
and how do people feel about that when it's like
that was grandpa john he's got to be in the story
he was a big part of the family but there wasn't
enough and I'm like you can put grandpa john in
the book for grandpa john but that's not going to
help your book we need to focus on the book what
does the book need what is you know maybe you can
write a little letter to grandpa john or something
put them in the put them in the acknowledgements
okay right with a picture no well that's right
we're not doing pictures no pictures no graphics.
What did you like about this video?